is fast X the Blockbuster of the summer
or is it limping past critics with a
flat tire Twitter has some things to say
about the film and they aren't all nice
you might want to buckle up just under
two years after the premiere of F9 The
Fast and Furious franchise has zoomed
back into Cinemas director Louis
letterier's fastax the 10th installment
in the main pass Saga has made its
theatrical debut promising audiences a
high octane pedal to the metal movie
going experience in this film Dom
Toretto will bring his family together
to face off with a maniacal Dante Reyes
who's out to get revenge on the heroes
reactions from those who got to see
fastex early arrived online ahead of its
release and for the most part folks seem
to be satisfied with the sequel sure
it's not the tightest story and can lean
on the side of style over that of
substance but overall it's been regarded
as a strong Blockbuster most agree that
Momoa is a standout as Dante and that
the action and drama or befitting of a
fast and furious sequel generally it
sounds like an enjoyable cinematic
Thrill Ride that left most folks
thoroughly entertained one Twitter user
wrote in their Mini review I had a blast
at fast Stacks like the most fun I've
had in the theater since Barbarian
another user called the film gloriously
and hilariously stupid in their tweet
and clarified that yes that meant they
enjoyed
come on
meanwhile another tweet points out that
the pacing isn't perfect but it doesn't
ultimately detract from the film's fun
Factor summing up their review by saying
they have a lot of fun and do a lot of
cool things with the storytelling and
filmmaking echoing similar thoughts
about the fun of fast X another user
recommends that those going to see it
just shut off their brains for a little
while and enjoy the ride meanwhile at
least one person notes that fastx
doesn't do much to stand out from the
rest of the Fast and Furious movies but
it's still an excellent watch commenting
you get cars breaking physics you get
funny moments and of course family
alongside the action flashy camera work
and pinches of Comedy fastx has also
been touted by fans as a movie with a
few notable surprises up its sleeve
do you like surprises I adore them
according to fans one of the most
surprising elements of the film is Jason
momoa's Dante Reyes the majority of fans
online seem to agree with critics at his
over-the-top performances the unexpected
highlight of the entire movie One user
claimed that Dante is the best fast and
furious villain while another said that
Momoa carries fast decks on his own
making a pretty bold claim another user
tweeted Jason Momoa deserves the Academy
Award this year because in fast acts he
is the MVP not the past family in
addition to mamoa's surprisingly seen
stealing performance past ex viewers
were shocked by the film's Cliffhanger
ending as well one that is garnered
largely negative reactions Twitter users
were quick to complain about the ending
with one person stating that the
conclusion makes fastax feel like an
incomplete movie comparing it to other
franchise endings another user wrote
Furious 7 perfect ending Furious 8
watchable fast 9 I have no words too
chaotic fast x what is going on here
I smell Magic
foreign